anyone named dan who says they own
something
you better just actually assume that
they rented it because
this is the second story like this in
basically a week
last week we talked about dan bilzerian
who rented his mcmansion
after saying that he owned it he said oh
yeah it's this multi-million dollar
property kevin o'leary goes and puffs it
up and builds a whole little video about
it about
dan bilzerian's cool lifestyle what a
baller except it turns out the whole
thing's rented and he gets kicked out of
ultimately the mansion now a very
similar thing just happened with dan lok
just yesterday we got a report in the
vancouver sun saying
entrepreneur sued for alleged failure to
pay rent on west vancouver home
and who is that entrepreneur failing to
pay rent allegedly
damn lock uh now
i know it's probably not right of me to
feel such a sense of
shot and freud but i do nonetheless
i love this stuff i love when these guys
who are
faking a phony lifestyle get busted baby
and this stuff always comes out
in funny ways like we would have never
figured this out unless basically dan
lok got sued by the
landlord now a little back story dan lok
and ryan sirhant who is you guys know
him he does all the multi-million dollar
listings
uh they teamed up and collabed on a
video where ryan zerghan went and toured
this guy's mansion and the title of this
video i just want to read this off to
you guys
because this is the part of the phony
lifestyle 35 million dollar
canada mansion tour with dan lok and
you're going through it and you see the
11 bedrooms you see the 16 000 square
feet you see the arcade the aquarium
bowling alley
all that kind of crazy stuff and you're
thinking to yourself wow how can this
guy be phony if he's got such a crazy
mansion that he lives in
you know he must be legit
oh yeah sometimes it's really good to be
me you guys
i gotta say when this stuff comes out
when this stuff
hits the press oh it's really good to be
the one true seafood
you know what i mean i i just want to
say the reason
you're never gonna find out that i
rented this hat or i rented my whistle
it's because i live within my means boys
i don't go
and buy these crazy lifestyle things
because ultimately
you don't need that in your life but
these guys they're appealing to poor
people who want to be rich so they got
to live that rich
lifestyle and so part of that is buying
the lambo well actually renting the
lambo of course you end up finding out
part of it's renting the bentley part of
it's renting
the 35 million dollar mansion whatever
and just inflating your own sense of
worth
and ego but it all catches up with you
and so with this i want to address two
things number one
these guys that they do the apartment
tours the multi-million dollar mansions
stop omitting that the person is renting
if
they're renting this is a facade
it's a rental right this is ultimately a
rental dan lok ostensibly cannot afford
living here
he says himself that if you can't afford
living somewhere just rent it with your
current income
you may not be able to buy at all and
that's okay
because it might take you years and
decades to save up enough money
just for the down payment and then even
then it's always a stretch
to make that monthly mortgage payment
then don't buy
rent but there's something else that
gets to me too don't inflate the price
of the home for your clickbait right
just put how much it's actually worth
because ryan sirhan i mean i guess maybe
this is just too nitpicky
he puts 35 million canada mansion tour
but actually
in the vancouver sun it's listed
actually at only being worth 13 million
dollars now i know that maybe does it
sound like a big difference
but it actually is it's worth half of
what ryan sirhan's saying it's worth
also ryan sirhan saying it has 11
bedrooms
here it's saying it has eight bedrooms i
mean look can we just be honest about
what these guys own what these guys ran
what these guys do because i'm just so
sick of this
false influencer instagram lifestyle
that's not
real i feel like this is a perfect
microcosm of the whole guru experience
they say they're worth this they're
actually worth half of that and they're
renting everything they own
so uh that's it for now just wanted to
make a quick one reporting on this
because like literally probably 10 or 15
of you have already sent me this link
and so i knew how i had to report on it
since we have such a history with dan
lok
but uh yeah have a good one and don't
forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
then don't buy rent